there is nothing automatic about
technological progress bringing these
gains during
almost every episode of major
technological transitions what we see is
that a there are many losers from that
process as you pointed out but even more
importantly B the phase of widespread
gains did not arise by itself or
automatically it was almost always a
struggle to get there
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast one of my favorite academics so
this is uh my first time having him on
the podcast the co-author of power in
progress our 1 000 year struggle over
technology and prosperity MIT economics
and poverty researcher and Professor
Darren smoglew Darren welcome thank you
Andrew it's a true pleasure to be here
with you the pleasure is all mine wow
what a book this was uh I mean we'll
we'll go into uh the idea behind it but
I cited you in the war on normal people
about your research on uh Rising deaths
of Despair and struggles of poverty in
America
um how did you come to that work and I
remember that I used a quote from you
where you were stunned by the findings
which was that American life expectancy
was actually going down not up yeah I
mean I think this is part of a broader
Trend uh a number of people have noted
what a striking reversal this is because
if you look at U.S data data for other
industrialized nations even almost all
developing countries in the 20 20 and
21st century you see this striking
increase in life expectancy and in the
United States in the 2010s you see a
reversal the people who really build on
that and develop that at Great length
with a fantastic book is our Angus
Deaton and Anne case and I draw on their
work
and the reason why I think this is so
important is because
I see it as
very closely connected to the overall
poverty inequality and wage patterns the
other striking thing in the United
States again pretty much unparalleled
anywhere else is that if you look at low
education workers their real incomes
have been declining for about 35 years
strikingly I mean again this is just
unseen in any industrialized Nation so
let's give someone a very quick capsule
bio of yours you were born in Turkey you
were an economics professor at MIT how
would you describe your research and the
work that you do
well you know I came into economics
because
I was passionate about understanding
democracy and economic prosperity
little did I know when I first came into
economics that you know many of these
topics were not the ones that economists
focused on you know in the 1990s you
know we studied markets and supply and
demand but you know big questions about
democracy and so on who were off the
table but as soon as I started exploring
these issues it was quite obvious to me
that technological change and Innovation
were also at the heart of the problem
and so a lot of my research is about
what triggers technological progress big
innovation breakthroughs and what their
consequences are what their inequality
implications are who wins who loses
and uh a lot of that was academic work
and then it started
being more
amenable to public discourse because
inequality became a major issue in this
country
and technological change is around us
and I think debates about what
technology is doing to our society are
becoming more Central so the power and
progress book is the culmination of all
of this research and thinking
yeah so uh your latest book power in
progress makes an argument uh that's
similar to frankly an argument I made
when I was running for president in the
last cycle
um no no there's this very very big
Fisher uh or divide one one has uh when
you think about
technological progress and its effect on
human Prosperity so the main one is hey
every time something gets invented we
become more prosperous it's great and
even if it's not you directly it's going
to be one of these Rising tide lifts all
boats scenarios so we should all
cheerlead for Progress now the other
side of the coin is hey when these
Technologies get adopted they kick
certain people to the curb they make
certain people richer certain firms uh
more Central and and Powerful right now
the main technology people think of and
this is AI and AI is going to benefit a
certain number of the very large Tech
firms uh and their their shareholders
presumably and then there may be lots of
workers who are on the outside looking
in so your book makes a very very
important and I will say comprehensive
historically documented argument about
which of these two we should be looking
at and you say look it's it doesn't
happen on its own it's actually a result
of a lot of social economic and
political choices so if you were to sum
up for people does technology mean that
we all get richer and more prosperous
well your your description and your
emphasis are 100 on target yes indeed
this is very coherent uh consistent with
your emphasis and the way I put it when
discussing this issue is that you have
to have
two potentially conflicting
frames in your mind one is no doubt we
are amazingly
fortunate to be living today rather than
say 300 years ago
and that's largely because of Industrial
Technologies and scientific
breakthroughs that have then been
applied to our lives so we are
beneficiaries of technological progress
we are so much more healthier so much
more comfortable so much more prosperous
so much more secure than people 300 250
years ago but conflicting with that
there is nothing automatic about
technological progress bringing these
gains
during
almost every episode of major
technological transitions what we see is
that a there are many losers from that
process as you pointed out but even more
importantly B the phase of widespread
gains did not arise by itself or
automatically it was almost always a
struggle to get there
so sometimes when we talk about these
issues and I'm sure you got this a lot
Andrew as well you get the question so
are you saying that this time is
different because we've always benefited
from technology in the past so you must
be saying this time is different and
this book is saying no this time is no
different in the past two we've had
these struggles we've had many people
who've been damaged by technology when
it wasn't appropriately used for example
the Industrial Revolution to which we
owe our prosperity led to lower incomes
much harsher working conditions much
lower life expectancy for about 100
years for the working people yeah and
that's what your book painstakingly does
is it goes out through history and says
okay when there was a Great Leap Forward
technologically uh did everyone feel the
benefits
and so you you go through major examples
and uh the answer is a lot of the times
people did not feel the benefits
starting with the development of even
Agriculture and and farming uh in Europe
where it turns out that there were some
land owners and then a bunch of serfs
I mean you know and again you know how
can
that
things would be so seamless when almost
all land almost all technology almost
all power was so concentrated and it
wasn't you know another example even
closer to home is the cotton gin the
United States
became the largest exporter of cotton
and the Southern economy was completely
revolutionized by the ability to plant
cotton that could then be cleaned on a
massive scale but who were the producers
where they were the enslaved black
people did they benefit hell no their
conditions became much harsher on Cotton
plantations longer working hours they
were moved to the further Deep South and
of course again
you don't expect their conditions to
improve seamlessly because they were in
an enslaved relationship
so power matters what we're doing with
technology matters AI is so amazing
because it's so versatile so that makes
these issues more important less
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like
five percent of people do the math for
100 night free trial you can sleep on
this thing for three months it will keep
you cool don't just take my word for it
my kids seek out this mattress in the
house it's the number one rated mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine this
mattress will actually make you happier
healthier and more productive Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yang this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now
[Music]
we talked about the Industrial
Revolution and that your book uh does
say there's been one major example of
rising prosperity and that's uh the U.S
post-world War II where there were all
these gains but they were broadly felt
um and but there was a lot of work that
went into that absolutely I think you
know if we want to be a little bit more
historical
the character of growth
changes starting in the second half of
the 19th century in the UK and perhaps
around the same time a little earlier a
little later in the United States
you have much more emphasis
on increasing the productivity of
workers
and you have
somewhat more worker voice for example
in the UK
trade unions were completely
uh illegal and prosecuted for much of
the 19th century they become legal
democracy settles in in the United
States there is greater voice for
workers but it's haphazard you know
Henry Ford who's a great amazing leader
when it comes to spearheading new
technologies that have been foundational
for mass production new tasks for
workers much greater worker productivity
and higher wages but he was very
anti-union for example and he could get
away with it so the post-war period is
unique in the United States and most of
the rest of the industrialized World in
a couple of ways first of all you see
this tremendously fast progress in terms
of GDP per capita and it is very very
broadly shared in fact from 19 late
1940s to the mid-1970s inequality
declines in the United States and much
of the Western World you see real wages
for workers of all education groups
rising in Tandem and this is Again
underpinned by a particular direction of
technological progress that was very
human complementary augmenting workers
creating new tasks for them and workers
had voiced through the Democratic
process through Labor organizations and
so on but of course you know
that era came to an end
I think we learn as much from
understanding how the economy worked
during those 30 35 years as from the
process
via which it actually started unraveling
from the 1980s onwards you see much
greater inequality actually slow
productivity progress actually to
productivity growth is slower
and you see many dimensions of
technological change being much less
pro-worker more automation more
surveillance less investment in workers
I think that's the Ensemble of the
economy and politics that we have to
understand when we move into the age of
Ai No when I was running for president I
was in Iowa and I met with some UAW
workers UAW drunk in there but they gave
me a movie to watch at home it's called
Brothers on the line uh and it talks
about the early days of the UAW there
was a leader named Walter Ruther
and Walter Ruther had multiple
assassination attempts uh in his home
one of his family members get shot like
that things that are really beyond the
panel and you're reading this you're
like oh my gosh what the heck uh he got
beaten multiple times uh and and reading
and watching this
um it made you realize just what a
Titanic struggle it was was four workers
to get certain benefits and there was
this rise of organized labor throughout
much of the period we're describing and
then it goes into reverse uh starting in
the 70s when as we're having this
conversation I want to say only maybe 10
or 11 of the U.S labor force is
unionized and it was over double that
level uh in let's say the 60s absolutely
100 and look you know
I think the U.S labor history is fraught
with problems
on both sides Luther was actually a very
interesting figure because he was one of
those who understood that he had to work
with companies and he had to create a
Cooperative environment in which
labor had a voice not just in working
conditions and wages but also in
technology so that was an amazing
Insight but most of the business World
tried to bash unions and most of the
unions didn't really
Focus attention on where they should
have done which is how we're using
Technologies how can we cooperate with
managers
and businesses so that we get the most
out of technology for our workers you
see that actually in some European cases
in Germany in the Nordic countries the
kind of corporatist model with or
workers on on company boards
facilitating this conversation about
technology so that workers are part of
the beneficiaries and part of the
conversation about Technologies and
actually quite frankly writer's Guild of
America
is sort of grappling towards that it's
perhaps the first postmodern uh strike
where the issue is AI who controls
creative data and perhaps can we find a
way of using these Technologies for the
betterment of the workers in this case
writers perhaps directors perhaps actors
as well I think those are the sorts of
issues that we have to be focusing on
and the labor movement should be
focusing on
laughs
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
yeah the the actors has joined that
strike uh and that that strikes uh I
think we're going to be very very
significant in terms of scope and
duration in part because the studios
want to use AI uh to let's say
supplement uh the talent where I mean
that's being kind of euphemistic
obviously they're saying hey act or you
come in we'll get your likeness uh and
then we can actually make use of it uh
with AI or your voice in particular I
mean they're very good at audio uh
replication and simulation and not
surprisingly the actors and the writers
are saying forget that you know we got
to get paid for our time and our work so
uh Walter Ruther was one of the
organizers of the uh March on Washington
where MLK had
um gave the I Have a Dream speech uh you
know he they were making common calls
with the the Civil Rights Movement at
that time and it made you realize wow
there was like this very very robust
unified popular movement or is Unified
as you can imagine that has really been
dramatically
weakened and changed over the the
succeeding decades what's happening now
with the writers and actors I think uh
is very emblematic but it's also uh
someone unusual in American life because
only one in 10 American workers is part
of a union so one of the things that
people will say is organized labor is
getting stronger because you're seeing
Amazon have some unionization efforts uh
and other employers that hadn't had it
previously I will confess that as as a
numbers guy it's like look if you take
it from let's call it 21 of the
population to 10 and then it goes
developed to 11
it would be an incredibly dramatic
change from where we are now because you
would have increased the number of you
know proportional unionized workers by
uh 10 of what it currently is
um but in the the scope of the economy
and and uh you know it strikes me that
that might be a very difficult path to
recreate absolutely look the labor
movement is weak but even worse
I don't think the old model of unions
centered on blue color workers
is the right one for the future so we
need to find a new model of worker voice
it has to be perhaps more inclusive in
terms of what sectors what types of
skills it covers
and you know
the future is gonna be
a lot of White Collar work knowledge
work
in-person Services the issues are quite
different
Amazon workers Starbucks workers you
know they're they're grappling with some
of these things but you know when it
comes to knowledge work what sort of
worker voice we want how that work is
going to be organized how we're going to
use Technologies now this is a unique
moment
because among the knowledge workers
writer's Guild is the only one that's
actually organized
but more importantly absolutely like you
said the studios are very interested in
using AI in order to cut labor costs
but they're not there yet the current
technology despite all of the hype the
large language models they cannot do
anything
approaching the type of creative work
that writer screenwriters can do at the
moment but the future is visible that
more of that will be available so right
now we have the issues quite clear so we
have to negotiate on them I think this
is kind of a unique moment
if writer's Guild get the right issues
on the table
they can build a sort of compact with
the employers I think that can be a
model for other sectors and I think
key problem here
very much along the lines of your
emphasis in the past is
is this technology going to be used for
just automation for example are we going
to use large language models to take a
lot of sitcoms and write some cheap not
so good versions of Seinfeld or friends
or can we use them in a way that is
complementary to writers that becomes a
tool in their hands for research for
information filtration for inspiration
but they control their own creative
process and their own creative data I
think those two are very different
Visions they require different types of
investments in the technology and they
also require different type of Labor
Management relation
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
yeah you reference essentially owning
your own data or work uh and now that
data is getting used to train the large
language models uh and you're not
compensated for that so a lot of writers
feel like they're writing their way out
of a job because their work's getting
used uh to improve Ai and a lot of
Americans I dare say feel that way uh
you're right about the writers being one
of the only organized white-collar
groups that could make this fight uh one
group that I think of is journalists and
50 or 60 000 journalists lost their jobs
over the last 15 20 years I imagine at
least some of them might have been
unionized in some of these environments
but that there really was no fight uh
and you'd look at it and say well it's
because these local newspapers were
dying and there wasn't much of a
negotiation going on
um but you still do have at least
certain media companies that
um are quite profitable uh you know and
and one of those New York Times I think
there's a unionization effort
um going on over there
um so so the writers are somewhat
singular now you make a case and this is
one reason why I like both your work and
your book is that you didn't do what
some people do is like hey this stuff's
going on and uh and
um you know let's hope for the best
you actually make the case and say okay
here's what you need number one you need
a new narrative number two you need a
coalition of countervailing interests
and then number three you need some
policies you're going for
um so let's start with number one what
is the conventional narrative and then
what do you think the new narrative
should be or has to be thank you Andrew
I think that's really to me 50 of the
fight is that new narrative and that
means first of all we agree on
what are feasible and desirable
aspirations
and there I think to me
that's quite obvious we want Ai and
other new technologies but especially AI
to go in a pro-human Direction
be a tool in the hands of humans
from all backgrounds make them more
productive more informed better citizens
better workers
not disempowered them Empower them
I think we have to agree on this again
not everybody would agree with that some
people may agree
on the outside but in the inside they
say no wouldn't it be better if we could
just eliminate these workers and some
people who say that's not feasible then
we get into some technical discussions
that's why you know in the book we go
back to the sort of competing visions of
what machines and what digital
Technologies are about are they going to
be
inevitable
autonomous machine intelligent type of
objects or could they be tools for
humans machines that are useful to
humans I think those two visions are
going to be Central to it and then once
we agree on this aspiration I think the
narrative is about whether if there is
something good technology will naturally
go to it sort of the Techno Optimus view
or whether we can entrust it to some
techno Geniuses be it some Outlet today
or whether it was Bill Gates in the past
so sort of great people obviously very
creative but can we and trust them
because they're going to follow their
own Vision they're going to follow their
own interests and if we just entrust
them you know if we trust them too much
if we Empower them too much then
alternative voices are going to be
drowned so the narrative is about what
we want and how Society can have a voice
in it via the competitive process new
firms entering but also through sort of
the deliberation the Democratic process
the media Civil Society organizations
podcasts people sort of expressing their
concerns their views their alternative
paths towards it you talk about look
that there's a handful of technologists
that kind of dominate the discourse uh
and they naturally will not be making
this more human-centered case so let's
say that you have a human-centered case
and you say we should be at the center
of the set of innovation and we
shouldn't expect this just to magically
happen which by the way I see all the
time
out there I'm sure you do too it's like
oh don't worry you know magical stuff
invisible hand I was like look the the
invisible hands is gonna
scrub out a lot of people on this one
the Invisible Hand and if you question
it you're a lotite yes yeah no I mean
hey take it from the MIT economics
professor that you know you might need
you might need to do a little more uh so
then then you have this uh Coalition of
interests who come together and I guess
you cited many of them just now
um uh where you you talk about various
interest groups um which at this point
should be most of us since I think most
of us realize that we're somewhat
subject to this
um and then clear policy goals uh and
you make cases for some pretty big
policy Investments uh including
strengthening the the social safety net
in the US absolutely absolutely look I
think
The Narrative has to change
you need this to be embedded in an
Institutional grounding countervailing
Powers you know better working democracy
but at the end of the day technology is
not going to take care of itself unless
you want to just follow the same path so
you need some sort of inducements for
different types of new technologies to
emerge and the current equilibrium to be
modified so for that we need policies we
need the right policies nobody knows
what these policies are
and there's a very good reason for that
because we haven't been experimenting
with them
everybody says our way you know I accept
now that we need some AI regulation but
we don't know what AI regulation should
look like because we have completely
abrogated our responsibility to regulate
digital Technologies for at least the
last one two two decades probably more
so those policies have to be viewed as
ideas that need to be explored more
but they gained it objectives are very
clear this country has reached a level
of inequality and poverty that's really
unacceptable in the 21st century with
such
great abundance that exists around us so
we have to strengthen the social safety
net absolutely
but there I also think
it's not just a social safety net
because I don't think a society in which
earned income is very very unequal
and then we just
create a somewhat more equal
distribution by taxes and transfers
would be a happy one it would create a
huge status inequality it would be
always subject to inequality again
exploding even more and the political
equilibrium being captured by the people
who have the income and quite honestly I
actually think we can do better because
if we can use AI in a more pro-human
pro-worker Direction I think we can
create the kinds of good jobs that were
the
you know Mainstay of the middle class
existence that the United States was so
good at for most of the 20 most of the
the post-war era
some things we do in public some things
we do in private and we certainly would
like to be able to know that when we're
alone we're actually getting our privacy
online is the same thing your online
privacy is just as important as in the
real world that's why I use expressvpn
when I'm online because I don't want my
internet service provider to know every
website I visit nor do I want them to
sell my data to Big tech companies
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
connection a tunnel between your device
and the internet no one can see it it
works on any device all you have to do
is fire up the expressvpn app click one
button it's as easy as that I recommend
this Fortune 500 companies use
expressvpn for good reason and you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
free by going to expressvpn.com Yang
that's
expressvpn.com Yang for three extra
months free 3. expressvpn.com yang
[Music]
so what has your experience been since
you've written this book uh come out
um you and Simon Johnson your
collaborator are both really really
admired and respected in your field uh
you've written best-selling books before
this so uh are how are people taking to
this case you're making well look I
think so far
I see three sets of responses which is
sort of inevitable I think for any book
like this I think we've had very very
good reception from Europe
the UK
Market has been very active with
newspapers policy makers being very
interested and in the United States the
same sort of interest from policy makers
and intellectual groups I think uh
that's been that's been great so the
conversation when we have been part of
it on these topics
has been really uplifting because it
shows there are lots of new ideas there
is energy there's concern there's
positive concern not the sort of that
says oh you know uh Killer Robots are
coming we should just hide under our
mattresses no we can do something about
this so so that's that's the positive
side the second you know it's also
inevitable is some sometimes silence
people just ignore it I think I would
love this book to be more
part of the conversation in the tech
world because I think the Nexus of many
of these changes is going to be the tech
World there are so many people working
in the tech industry who are very
concerned who recognize that the
Machinery that they are part of is not
always functioning for the social good
but they don't know they can't always
identify what the root cause of these
problems are and what they can do I
think they need to be part of this
conversation so I think your uh sort of
voice here is really important to sort
of bring
these sorts of issues even more to the
attention of the tech world and then of
course there has been some you know uh
hostile reactions uh I think some people
read the book as a very interventionist
book so some free market Outlets such as
the Wall Street Journal have not been
very receptive to it but I think at the
end of the day yes of course we do make
some bold policy
uh proposals but I think we are making
them in the spirit of saving the market
system
because I I made the same argument for
sure right you know fun Market
fundamentalism is actually its worst
enemy yeah uh so so I really don't see
the book as a partisan one and I think
exactly like in the spirit that you are
presenting your ideas as well these are
not partisan ideas I would love it if
Republicans picked up on some of these
ideas
markets don't function very well if you
don't have a middle class and a bit of
people don't have the ability to
participate you don't regulate them I
mean I think we learned we learned a
wrong long wrong lesson from the success
of the Us and other European economies
relative to the Soviet Union
the euphoric feeling after the fall of
the Berlin world was oh yeah at the end
of History you know capitalism is
triumphant and the alternatives are
obliterated yes to some degree the U.S
European system
was Victorious but that's because it was
a regulated market system and then by
dismantling these regulations at that
Breakneck speed
we've actually made it much harder for
that market system
well it's very hard to argue with your
book in my opinion because you backed it
up with literally hundreds of years of
data and history you know
what went through all these major
technological shifts I mean the the
canal stories crazy
with those of you who want to dig into
it um that there's a story early in the
book about how there was a point when
canals were the brand new technology and
let's just say it didn't go well you
know that's such an interesting story
because it epitomizes some things that
we can see with our own eyes today
techno optimism
people thinking oh you know these
problems are gonna solve themselves and
if we hit roadblocks new technologies
will come to solve them hubris you know
the the the sort of the main character
the protagonist of that story is
Ferdinando lesseps who
had a very powerful vision of techno
optimism and opening markets and he was
very successful in Suez
against the odds and against the views
of many establishment people and that
meant that he became both himself
hebrewistic and then the whole sort of
surrounding environment became
completely beholden to him which made
him walk into a complete disaster in
Panama technologies that could not work
no attention to details 22 000 people
dead uh because of bad planning so we
hope that we learn from those sorts of
historical episodes you know I I say
that's a fitting note to end on
Jared let's not be the 22 000 Canal
workers who just expected to work out
power in progress our 1 000 year
struggle over technology and prosperity
a very smart learned man who's trying to
help Humanity Darren has some ogloo
Darren if someone wants to keep up with
you how can they best do so uh I have a
Twitter account also email at Daron
mit.edu I would love to hear feedback
and other information thank you I can
attest that that email works because
that's how I got a hold of Darren Darren
thank you keep up the awesome work my
friend thank you Andrew this was a
really true pleasure and privilege to be
on your podcast wonderful conversation
[Music]
thank you